this episode is brought to you by
curiosity streams a subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries and non-fiction titles
right now you guys can get 25 off the
cost of a subscription
more on them in just a bit
the saying goes some are born to
greatness while others have greatness
thrust upon them it's a pity phrase one
which seems to capture some vague truth
about the world but it also fails to
encapsulate today's subject to have
greatness thrust upon them is too
passive implying you're either great
from birth or become so due to the
actions of others but there was nothing
passive about father miguel hidalgo's
moment in history after decades as an
anonymous nobody he didn't so much have
greatness thrust upon him as he did grab
it by the balls and make it squeal the
mercy a scandalous priest in mexico's
bahia region hidalgo jumped headlong
into history with his 1810 cry of
dolores appearing for equality that
echoed far beyond his parish coming at a
time of chronic instability it inspired
the uprising that became the mexican war
of independence but how did this happen
how did the actions of one small town
priest wind up changing north american
history while the answer lies in a tale
of chaos revolution and heartbreaking
tragedy
if your mental image of a mexican
revolutionary is of a glorious
mustachioed peasant warrior then the
early life of miguel hidalgo might
surprise you born on may the 8th 1753 in
a hassy end near the silver mining city
of guanajuato hidalgo didn't grow up in
a cruel heart gravel world but one of
comparative luxury his family see were
creolos people of pure european descent
born in the spanish colony of new spain
numbering about 1 million they were the
comfortable middle class of the
viceroyalty the wealthy types who filled
the priesthood and junior officer ranks
below them groaned two vast lower
classes the part european part
indigenous mestizos and the pureblood
indians the impoverished majority of the
population in the socially stratified
colony these were the ones who scraped
by so criollos could live their easy
lives but while the criollos were near
the top of this miserable period they
weren't at the pinnacle that place was
reserved the europeans who'd been born
in spain itself the peninsulares if the
criollos were the priests and junior
officers the peninsulares were the
generals and archbishops the elite of
the elite numbering a mere 15 000 in a
colony of 6 million they wielded their
privilege like a jewel encrusted club
insisting the tropical climate made the
creoles mentally inferior to those born
in europe this meant a ban on creole
officers advancing past captain on creo
priests becoming bishops on families
progressing no matter how much money or
prestige they had it was a crazy
divisive policy one which helped foster
resentment among even the most powerful
criollos miguel hitargo's family were
less powerful than most despite being of
european descent hidago's father was
relatively poor he didn't own a hacienda
but managed one keeping in close contact
with the indians doing all of the real
work that mentidalgo grew up with an
insight into the lives of the lower
classes that his contemporaries lacked
even learning three native languages
still the boy had more opportunities
than most new spain residents
opportunities like studying in
valladolid today mourinho mexico for his
degree in philosophy and theology from
there it was an easy stroll across the
concerted halls of affluence into the
priesthood but while he may have been
ordained father hidalgo was never a
priestly during his time teaching at
collegio de san nicolas hidalgo treated
his ecclesiastical job as lesser calling
and more of a game of see how much i can
get away with before the boss fires my
ass a lifelong gambler hidalgo's idea of
a good time was going partying winning
big then hooking up with one of his
mistresses to jointly piss on his vow of
celibacy over his lifetime he'd live in
sin with multiple women some multiple
children and generally have the sort of
fun times the church typically frowns on
but we'd be doing the padre a disservice
if we painted him as merely a loose
fornicator because hidalgo was an
incisive free thinker as a priest
hidalgo was one of the few people in new
spain allowed to read heretical books on
the assumption that he'd then write
clever tracts refuting them instead he
seems to have enjoyed swimming in
blasphemous thought devouring the works
of great enlightenment thinkers
absorbing ideas of natural law and
social justice in this he was ironically
encouraged by the prelate manuel abbad
iquepo peninsulare who felt sorry for
new spain's impoverished millions no
doubt quiepo envisioned hidalgo becoming
like him a loyal colonial foot soldier
who nonetheless tinkered with social
problems trying to alleviate misery this
is probably why quipo helped the younger
man get trially transferred after he got
in trouble with debt rather than
defrocking him but it wouldn't be as a
good colonial tinkering with new spain's
social system that hitalgo found his
fame oh no instead he'd soon blow the
whole rotten edifice sky high
for a decade after leaving collegio to
san nicolas hidalgo bounced around
working in various villages even
surviving a brush with the one thing
nobody expects the spanish inquisition
it was only in 1803 that he wound up in
the town that today bears his name
dolores hidalgo of course it was just
plain old dolores when the priest first
rolled up a typical bio town with
typical bio problems and in this era
there were plenty of them famous for it
silver the buyer had been plunged into a
prolonged depression by a global price
crash so bad was the sum that it wasn't
just the indian mine workers who were
suffering but also the mestizos and even
the creoles for donita argo this was the
exact sort of social challenge that he
was born to deal with as the town's new
priest he subcontracted his
ecclesiastical duties to an assistant
and instead focused on a grand plan to
restart the economy hidalgo's brainwave
was to get the locals working on more
varied self-sustaining cottage
industries rather than just relying on
the mines he bought silkworm so the
impoverished indians could learn to rear
them set up a series of terraces for
growing grapes to make wine it was an
attempt to help dolores stand on its own
feet to break the cycles of poverty
hidalgo saw across the bio but it was
also an opportunity to start putting
enlightenment ideas into practice by now
the priest had grown into a thin
50-something man with a shiny bald head
and eyes that were alive with both
intelligence and occasional flashes of
white-hot anger anger because as he kept
reading subversive literature hidalgo
was drifting more and more towards
politics to radical solutions to the
issues surrounding him nor was he the
only one amid its ongoing slum the
entire bayer was alive with literary
societies where cryos met blessed to
discuss literature and more to spend
hours ranting about the useless colonial
government yet it would be events taking
place over 9 000 kilometers away that
would turn these literary societies into
the touch paper for the mother of all
explosions while new spain had been
dealing with its own internal tensions
the mothership in madrid had been
dealing with a far greater external
threat the napoleonic wars in march 1808
french troops crossed the border forcing
charles iv to abdicate in favor of his
son ferdinand vii but then napoleon
decided this wasn't enough and it got
really crazy the abdications of baon saw
ferdinand imprisoned and forced to
abdicate in favor of napoleon's brother
joseph bonaparte the problem was spain's
entire empire rested on a legitimacy
drawn from the spanish throne place a
usurper on the throne and
well you could probably see how things
might go wrong from there in the
american colonies of new grenada and rio
de la plata the bonapartist coup did to
society what nitroglycerin does when
dropped into a gathering of clowns there
was pandemonium hunters claiming to
represent the deposed ferdinand sprang
up ready to fight those loyal to the
bonapartist regime in new spain the
creoles tried to do likewise but sensing
the whole viva ferdinand thing might be
code for let's replace the peninsulares
the peninsulares overthrew the
sympathetic viceroy and cracked down
hard on any sign of descent this way
they managed to keep a lid on the sort
of revolt springing up in south america
even as the peninsula war erupted back
home damaging madrid's ability to
administer an empire new spain remained
grudgingly stable but the peninsulares
could only delay the inevitable up in
the baeo the creolitary groups hidalgo
belonged to were starting to look at
this cruddy set up and wonder if they
couldn't do better ruling themselves by
the time 1810 rolled around they'd gone
from simply wondering it to outright
planning the unthinkable all right we'll
get back to today's video in just a
minute but first a word from today's
sponsor curiosity stream curiosity
stream is a subscription streaming
service that offers thousands of
documentaries and non-fiction titles
from some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals think of
it as the netflix for nerds the hulu for
history buffs curiosity streams
available on many platforms and web apps
including roku android xbox one smart
tvs ios chromecast amazon fire
application apple tv it's a lot of
places it's also offered worldwide and
it's constantly updated with amazing
timely content for example this spring
they added an eight-part series called
the bone detectives now if you like
biographies and we're gonna think good
day
baby head over to curiosity stream and
check out their bio documentaries on
alexander the great william the
conqueror and so many more famous names
you can also check out american icons a
nine part series that tells the story of
babe ruth eleanor roosevelt mark twain
and more
curiositystream.com is where you go for
unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series and
right now you guys can use the code
biographics to save 25 off the cost of
an annual subscription which comes out
to just 14.99 a year not a month per
year it's a great deal click the link
below or just go to curiositystream.com
biographics and you'll save 25 making it
just 14.99 for the whole year and now
back to today's video
in the annals of spectacular bad timing
it's hard to be francisco xavier
vernergas sent from spain to make sure
madrid retained control of its colonies
during the polionic upheavals vanagas
arrived in mexico city on september 14
1810 and if you know anything about
mexican history you know that this was
mere hours before everything exploded
ever since the peninsulares cou of 1808
the plot in the bio had been solidifying
intolora's father adaugo had opened a
new cottage industry for peasants
secretly manufacturing weapons meanwhile
the queretaro literary club at the heart
of it all had added important members
guys like creole captain ignacio de
allende or the wealthy juan de aldama by
the fall of 1810 their plans were nearly
ready in just a few short weeks they'd
be ready to overthrow the peninsulares
and install a pro-korea government only
a few short weeks would turn out to be
far longer than they actually had that
september officials contacted the mayor
of queretaro informing him of the
revolutionary plot in his city stupidly
they didn't realize the mayor's wife was
in on it when she heard the news she
immediately sounded the alarm september
15th saw ignacio de allende and quan del
aldama ride like hell from allende's
hometown of san miguel to dolores
arriving after midnight they woke father
hidalgo in his bed to tell him the game
was up it's at this point that hidalgo
finally reached out to grab greatness by
the nutsac rather than flee into hiding
the priest ordered the church bell's
rung summoning his congregation under
dark skies illuminated only by the light
of flickering torches he then gave the
single most famous speech in mexican
history grito de dolores the craft lores
a passionate howl for the end of bad
government the land rights of the
peasants and the overthrow of the
peninsulares the cry of dolores was
simply the most electrifying thing the
people had ever heard at hidalgo's word
the local creos mestizos and indians
were whipped into a near religious
further it was a seriously powerful
speech the only problem is that today we
have no idea what was said the speech
was spontaneous no one was taking notes
and so the text was lost luckily enough
people later wrote down the basic gist
that we know for certain what wasn't
said anything about independence while
this is the moment that kicks off the
mexican war of independence a break from
spain is not what hidalgo is calling for
rather he couched the uprising as a
fight for the imprisoned king ferdinand
vii to forge the sword of new spain he
would undoubtedly be proud of it was a
convenient fiction a way for hidalgo to
say
i'm not a traitor i'm fighting for our
rightful king while also not having to
actually consult that king on anything
regardless it still worked as dawn broke
over dolores on september 16th it was on
terrified peninsulares being dragged
from their beds and taken hostage on
captain allende gathering soldiers on
rioting peasants destroying
european-owned shops by the time the sun
was up hidalgo and allende were at the
head of a newly formed volunteer army of
around 800 men with nothing left to lose
they marched out in the direction of sam
miguel as they went the number swirled
for peasants in the villages the news of
a revolution against their hated
overlords was like an invitation to come
party they flocked to hidalgo's banner
until the ranks had swollen to four
thousand it was this mob that reached
san miguel that evening riding ahead
hende instructed his old comrades
guarding the town not to fight then went
to parlay with the terrified
peninsulares in exchange for surrender
he told them the mob would respect both
their lives and their property but it
turns out that impassioned mobs aren't
exactly great at keeping their promises
as soon as san miguel was opened the
impoverished army went on the rampage
breaking into peninsulare homes looting
their businesses and destroying anything
they couldn't take in the aftermath
allende freaked out telling hidalgo he
needed to control the mob but hidalgo
waved him off saying the promise of more
loot would attract more soldiers and
really there was little they could do to
stop it the cry of dolores had unleashed
something a restless anger that had been
stirring even before the downturn an
anger born of discrimination lost
opportunities and spending your life
stuck at the bottom of a dumb racial
hierarchy whether end they liked it or
not the mob was now on the warpath he
and hidalgo could try to fight it or
they could ride its anger into legend
[Music]
the speed with which hidalgo's army
swept new spain that autumn was nothing
short of astonishing and it really was
hidalgo's army now after san miguel
they'd marched on salea which the priest
had managed to take without bloodshed
simply by threatening to execute the 78
peninsulares that they were holding
hostage in the aftermath the ambitious
allende agreed to defer to the old man's
command of course that without bloodshed
bit only applied to the act of taking
the city once the gates opened there had
been more looting rioting and burning of
rich folks homes so horrifying was all
this pillaging that nearby settlements
went on high alert trying to arm
themselves against the oncoming storm
but it's worth remembering that the
destruction was only horrifying for
elites in guanajuato the towns mositos
and indians were so enthused to hear
about all these europeans dying that
governor ayano abandoned his original
defense plans instead hiding all 400
local peninsulares in the city's
imposing al-hondiga de granditus not
that it helped very much hidalgo arrived
at the town on september the 26th at the
head of twenty thousand men having taken
many smaller towns on route on their
rival ten thousand locals immediately
defected to their cause when the
combined army attacked the al hondiga
the outcome was inevitable the fierce
bloody battle saw governor ian shot
through his head the alhandiga set a
light and those inside massacred all
told some 2000 died in the fighting and
this
was only the beginning with the
algondiger still smoking governor ian's
body was tripped naked and hoisted up a
flagpole while the mob attacked the city
burning looting and killing their way
across town this time hidalgo tried to
stop them after two days of uproar
somewhere between carnival and the sack
of troy the priest commanded his men to
stop the violence in response they kept
right on rioting and here we get to the
eternal issue with hidalgo's army while
they were an army in the sense that they
followed their leader into battle they
were also at heart an unruly drunken mob
out to smash stuff being able to direct
where they smash stuff gave hidalgo real
power but it also left him vulnerable to
the mob's vagaries the rioting in
guanajuato that drove a not
insignificant number of cryos to side
with the peninsulares cryos who would
have signed on for a disciplined
revolution but were now terrified of
starring in a spanish sequel to the
reign of terror but don hidalgo had gone
too far
to back out now he might be getting
nervous about the violence displayed by
his followers but he also knew that this
was his best chance to change new spain
for the better and by this point the
padre had some serious changes in mind
privately he was admitting that he was
no longer interested in fighting for
ferdinand vii that an independent new
spain might be the way forward publicly
he was embracing the radical demands of
his peasant army the restitution of land
to indigenous peoples the outlawing of
slavery and perhaps unsurprisingly the
reduction of alcohol taxes he even
designed a new banner for his men to
march under one showing the virgin of
guadalupe a darker-skinned mary
worshiped by new spain's non-europeans
there was always an army that seemed to
speak for the colonies dispossessed far
more than it spoke for the criollos and
while this would soon cause problems for
now it gave hidalgo the raw manpower
that he needed on october the 17th the
army took valladolid without a fight
returning hidalgo to his old home for
the first time in decades with the city
pacified the priest went to the
cathedral recently vacated by his former
mentor manuel abbad e kipio who'd fled
after declaring hidalgo has communicated
and held a mass of thanksgiving three
days later his now 80 000 strong army
marched out again this time in the
direction of the biggest prize of all
mexico city
i remember francisco xavier venegas the
guy who arrived mexico city just in time
to have the worst first week of work
ever well he was watching hidalgo's army
approach with what we can only assume
was mounting dread as the last days of
safety slipped by he fortified the city
and debated whether to flee to veracruz
however he also did one very clever
thing with one of the only printing
presses in new spain under his command
venegas had reams of anti-hidalgo
propaganda printed pamphlets playing up
the atrocities in stark terms the hope
was he might turn people against the
arab priest that if vanegas and all the
other peninsulares survive they might be
able to recruit new supporters not that
surviving seemed like something venegas
would be able to put on his next cv on
october 30th hidalgo met the city's
defenders at the battle of monte de las
cruces while the fighting was super
costly for the priest two thousand of
his men died and another forty thousand
deserted it also ended in victory mexico
city was now wide open and it's here we
get to one of the biggest alternate
history mind
of all despite allende being all like
bro what are you waiting for attack
already hidalgo hesitated he tried to
open negotiations for a surrender and
there was no response he hesitated some
more and then after three whole days
camped before the trembling city the
priest did something astonishing he
ordered his men to pack up and turn
around today the consensus is that
miguel hidalgo blew it by not attacking
the capital despite depleted ranks he
could almost certainly have taken the
city and possibly have declared an
independent mexico then and there
instead the war of independence would
now drag on for another 10 years
outlasting all of the characters that
we've met today and leaving much of the
country an impoverished ruin the crazy
part no one knows for certain why
hidalgo retreated although there are
theories the most persuasive of which
involves general felix cayea assadango
advanced on the capital the growing
alliance of peninsulares and creoles
that we might as well start calling
royalists hadn't just been sitting
around waiting to die in san luis potosi
general care had raised an army the same
day hidalgo won the battle of monte de
les cruz says he'd attacked laura's
birthplace of the revolution sacking the
priest's home now is making his way
toward the capital a professional
soldier at the head of a small but
well-disciplined army some think hidalgo
sounded the retreat to avoid doing
battle with them in which case wow
that's a hell of an own goal by sheer
fluke hidalgo's retreat took him right
into the path of chaos forces the
subsequent battle that cuckoos saw the
rebels collapse into disorderly retreat
losing nearly a hundred men to kiera's
single casualty still it's not like the
defeat was decisive although they'd just
been humiliated the insurgents still
seemed to be riding a wave of
revolutionary feeling across the nation
peasant uprisings inspired by hidalgo
are capturing cities when the priest led
his demoralized army into one such city
guadalajara they were welcomed as heroes
nor was guadalajara the only place to
have fallen than november tepic sam
blass and san luis potosi were all
overwhelmed by peasant rebels inspired
by the news hidalgo spent his time in
the grand city establishing a
proto-state the first glimmerings of
what would eventually become independent
mexico yet even now danger was closing
in on november 24th chaos forces retook
guadalujarto sent to defend it andeo was
instead forced to flee in indominus
defeat it was a warning sign a grim
prophecy of what was to come miguel
hidalgo might feel like he was the
beginning of a grand fight for
independence but the truth was that his
part in it was already nearly over
as 1811 approached a feeling of paranoia
seemed to settle over the not quite so
government in guadalajara father hidalgo
became increasingly worried about
assassination employing a follower to
sip from his wine before he touched it a
prescient move since ande was
considering trying to poison him at the
same time arguments were erupting
between the two over tactics bender
would scream that they needed to abandon
guadalajara and turn to guerrilla
fighting to stand a chance of survival
but hidalgo refused he preferred the
idea of rolling everything on a single
confrontation between his army and
cuellar's confident the rebels manpower
advantage would carry the day it was a
gambler's move befitting the kind of
wayward young man the priest had been
back in vader lid yet there's just one
problem with big gambles when they go
wrong they go wrong spectacularly on
january the 16th 1811 word arrived the
chao was in striking distance some
sources say hidalgo told his men that
the next day they'd eat breakfast in
guadalajara and dinner in mexico city
instead the only thing hidalgo ate was a
supremely bitter serving of humble pie
taking place at the eponymous bridge the
battle of caudaron was the moment the
uprising died defeated by the superior
force hidalgo's men broke and fled
leaving guadalajara open to the
royalists while hidalgo and ayande both
escaped the captain was so enraged that
he arrested the priest taking control of
the remnants of the army and his plan
was to quick march north cross into the
usa and raise american mercenaries to
continue the fight but it would go no
better than hidalgo's plans for the
battle of calderon on march 21 1811 the
fleeing army entered the small
settlement of akatita
unaware that its creo soldiers had read
vanigaz's propaganda heard of the
atrocities and concluded that they'd
rather side with the royalists hidalgo
and juan al-marma were all arrested
dragged to chihuahua and put on trial on
june 26 allende and adama were both shot
by firing squid a month later it was a
dowgo's turn after being defrocked the
now ex-priest was led outside on july 30
1811. while he apologized for the
violence he supposedly refused to
disavow his dream of an independent
mexico miguel hidalgo e costilla was
executed age 58 a traitor in the eyes of
many of his fellow creoles afterwards
his head was cut off and sent to
guanajuato where it was hung from the
alhandiga for this former priest the
story was over but not for mexico
because the dream of independence didn't
die with don hidalgo for the next 10
years the war rumbled on before finally
ending in august 1821 with a shock rebel
victory and while the kind of free
mexico that emerged would bear far more
resemblance to the criollo dreams than
the radical far more equitable society
hidalgo had planned it would at least
remain out of madrid's clutches as
reached the end of this video then it's
fair to say that miguel hidalgo left
behind a legacy that's complex on the
one hand he was one of the most
important people in mexican history a
man without whom mexico as we know it
wouldn't even exist on the other he
failed to see his dream through to
completion instead it was left to those
who came after to try and build an
independent state to argue over what it
should look like and those arguments
would lead to decades of instability
it's often said that some are born to
greatness while others have greatness
thrust upon him but the life of father
hidalgo shows us there exists another
type of person those with the courage to
reach out and grasp greatness even if
only for a second just long enough
to change the world because make no
mistake without this one priest our
world today would look very different
now just before you leave today maybe
look for something else to watch why not
check out my new channel called wara
graphics want to know all of the details
about some of history's most famous
battles and wars come join me on wara
graphics from sherman's march to the sea
to operation barbarossa it's got people
fighting each other or occasionally
animals we will cover it there is a link
below